I've seen a lot of training footage in
my day I'm a bit of a perv but anyway
explain this to me why are you doing
this with your chief what are you
building
what do you you're lifting weights with
your mouth why what is that you would
wonder what benefits it has for boxing I
just think that like let's say for
instance like the pit bull dogs and you
know
look Josh strong jaw and wind wrong jar
yeah you're getting hit to the head and
you want every advantage possible so
that kind of strength is up the jaw area
the neck area and Mike Tyson in my
opinion was a guy who brought a lot of
the neck strength to the sport of boxing
so we're just trying to evolve it and
take it to another so are you developing
the back of the neck as well because
'old from you get knocked out sometimes
it's the it's the snap back of the head
and that what might prevent that yeah
yeah yes so all of these little things
make a difference that's incredible do
you do that now here's another thing I
have to ask you there's a lot of there's
an old fight mythology that you
shouldn't have sex for a while before
the fight do you do you follow that
it's an old for a long time there's
always an old timer like in the modern
era with the science and training do
people think that that's just kind of
silly now some would say yeah I would
say but I think it's just that sacrifice
anything that gives you any form of
pleasure when you're about to fight you
need to sacrifice that's why we call it
training camp take yourself away from
the luxuries and take yourself somewhere
where you can just have then focus and
that's why I think that stems from well
I'm sure there is fighters I've snuck
out of that training up at night you
know yeah that's all for some reason or
another they're tired in the morning
they have lied what they was doing that
night so yeah yeah of course
everybody should air on each of their
own right but for me I told them you
know keep on reproducing what tester and
in my opinion oh you think it I would
tell my fighters to keep on reproducing
reproducing the test idea which would
mean don't have sex or have
now I'm confused and that's an auto-fire
go figure out yourself son
you